- Morning, my boys!
- Morning, brotha!
- Breakfast times.
- Heads up Chef J!
- Guess we're just having
leftover Pad Thai.
- Let's go!
- It's an adventure
comedy movie, uh--
Sorry, can I take
that again?
- I mean...
Like, all of it
is pretty odd.
- We kind of wrote it just
being like,
"Surely we'll have to cut
a lot of this."
♪ Now watch me ooh ♪
♪ Crank that Soulja Boy ♪
♪ Now watch me ♪
- Oh, my God!
- Your boy's okay.
- Let's go!
- It is about three best friends
who set out to find treasure
hoping that will solve
all their problems.
And it either does
or doesn't.
- It's like
"Indiana Jones,"
but nothing like
"Indiana Jones."
- A hundred mil.
- A hundred million dollars?
- I mean, I know
it's more than this,
but at least
a million dollars each.
- Significantly more.
- So it's this kind of
silly look
at what it means
to grow up.
- All three of them were
born in 2018.
So these are very young kids,
and the script is ambitious.
- You're three hours late!
- Dad, you don't understand.
The Subs was busted,
so we had to shred.
- You had to shred?
- This is kind of
an autobiographical story.
Um, we all met,
and, uh...
We went to a mountain
and we found treasure.
- We started developing
the script
before they got
"Saturday Night Live."
And then they got
"Saturday Night Live,"
and then suddenly they were
really breaking out quickly,
and we thought
we had to do it.
- When I met Judd
and started talking to him,
with the guys, it just
happened very fast.
He was really behind it.
He really believed in it.
- Judd would say to me,
he's like,
"I'm having deja vu."
Those guys are how he
and Sandler were in their crew,
you know, 30 years ago.
- I'm more of a fan
of the blanket, myself.
- That's disgusting, dude.
That was such
a clean pop.
- In sixth grade,
we had to do a project
on heroes, like,
in the world.
Like, people chose, like,
Martin Luther King Jr.
And I chose Judd.
[laughing]
And my teacher was like,
"Who?" Like...
Like, "Who is this?"
And to be working with him,
it's truly amazing.
- It's almost like a flashback
when I was working
with my knucklehead friends,
you know,
on "Happy Gilmore" sets.
And then they introduced us
to all sorts
of really funny people
that are in their comic world.
- Ain't half bad.
- Yeah.
- Hey!
- Oh, my God.
- Oh...
- Do you guys want
a drink?
- Or should
I go fuck myself?
- A drink.
- Let's do a drink.
- Yeah, a drink.
- Am I doing my lines
too sexy?
[laughing]
- Sometimes you're forgetting
that we're not just, like,
in high school doing a play
and, like, having fun.
The script is so funny
that it feels really big,
but I think when you're
with your friends,
it feels like, oh, we're
just, like, hanging out
and having the best time,
and it doesn't feel
like work at all.
- John, Ben, and Martin,
you can't deny it.
They're so funny,
and they work so hard.
They have not had a day off
since top of the year
with SNL, and then
writing this.
- Yeah, we have so much
around here, man.
It's like a family.
- So kind.
Um, and I really
----ing hate them.
- Dude are you okay?
- I got the--
- I apologize for him.
- Oh, my God!
[laughter]
- The dial just turns up
the entire time.
Every scene is like
one more notch of intensity.
[screaming]
- We're sorry.
- Okay, okay, cut.
- We got really lucky
with, like, being able
to do most of the stuff
that we wanted to do.
- Wing suits.
- Wing suiting
through the sky...
[screaming]
- Oh, my God.
- Woah, woah, woah.
[screaming]
- You're like a kite.
- What?
- You're like my kite.
- Almost every scene
has some element of, like,
I can't believe that this
actually being shot.
- Oh, my God!
- Oh, my God.
- I got us here!
- Maybe we could have
wrote a version of it
that was happening
on the ground.
You live and you learn.
- I just seriously
bruised my taint.
- Making a movie.
Making a movie today.
- I'm an active hater
of Please Don't Destroy.
So I've been trying
to destroy them for years.
- How dare you interrupt
our sacred dance.
Okay, Tricia,
you need to punch some
fucking holes in this thing.
- I think they've done
a really good job
of ratching it up to something
so funny and absurd.
It's just a comedy that's
firing on a lot of cylinders.
- Gun it, Lisa.
- I really like
their work a lot.
They really
make me laugh.
So, when they told me
this was possible,
I thought, well,
that'd be cool.
'Cause this thing, well,
ups my sexual energy
and magnetism by 70%.
- The friendship is real,
it's authentic.
They have this thing that you
just want to root for them.
- We don't hang out
outside of this.
- What'd you say?
- I was just telling them
that this is
a professional relationship.
- Right.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Uh, yeah.
- There's kind of a magic
that they have
when they are together.
- I don't really speak
to Martin or John anymore.
- You feel it
in every frame that,
you know, these guys
love each other
and how tight they are,
and that they really
make each other laugh.
- We've been fighting,
and honestly,
I think that this could be
the end of our relationship.
- As we dug deeper
into our friendship,
the more that we could
write better jokes.
- It's a movie about guys
who work and live together,
and love each other,
and that is our life.
- It's what I've wanted
to do my whole life.
And to be able to do it
with my two best friends
is really cool.
- Mountain, compass,
treasure, friends.
Mountain, compass,
compass, friends.
Friends, treasure,
treasure, friends.
[growling]
- Oh, my God,
it's an animal!
[screaming]
- I'm gonna be sick
to my stomach.
- What was that?